okay I think I'm back
oh oh
oh my gosh wait
ah okay wait one one at my back and my
back okay guys I
it stopped and then it started again
it's just like
Vice
why can't I react
um okay hold on I'm gonna go to my live
stream okay guys hello hello get get
back in this chat
get back in the chat I'm gonna put this
monetization on from the last stream
because Pearl doesn't do this for free
all right
I gotta put this link in the chat okay
get back
all right hello guys can you believe
they did this to me all right I really
need you guys to fill out your emails
for this merch we're gonna drop we're
gonna be doing I want to do matchmaking
too I don't know I have so many ideas I
don't know which ones I'm gonna do but
all right
um I'm a little disappointed that I
can't react to my advice video it's a
bit
you know whatever I guess
okay let's see what do I want to react
to
ask me some questions in the chat while
I find a video
um
L Matrix
shouldn't marriage licenses be renewable
I was thinking about it but if you do a
marriage right license being renewable
then just be in a relationship like what
is the point of marriage what is the
point of marriage with no fault divorce
I was really thinking about this if you
can get out of marriage
then what's the point why have it
daily wire chocolate launch
someone said okay
okay
International women's day is upon us
again
and I love an international woman but
our friends over at Hershey's they don't
even know what a woman is they've hired
a biological male to be the spokesperson
for their women's day campaign and
they're calling that campaign and I
swear I'm not making this up her she
her sheep it's humiliating and it's the
reason that I'm launching
Jeremy's chocolate we have two kinds
she her
and he him
one of them's got nuts if you need me to
tell you which one it is
keep giving your money to Hershey's but
if you're tired of giving your money to
woke corporations that hate you and
you're looking for a delicious chocolate
bar from oh my gosh is that Brett Cooper
I did not realize that was Brett Cooper
oh my gosh right girl you're hot
oh my
okay right I see you
I see you corporations that hate you and
you're looking for a delicious chocolate
bar from a company that actually wants
your business head over to
ihatehersheys.com and Order Jeremy's
chocolate today
it was kind of funny
all right
um I was more I was more impressed
my girl us
when am I going on The Joe Rogan show
she wanted me on I don't think man would
um okay
what is I gonna add
um okay what I want to add in here
um
Brett sings
I swear I swear to God if you guys
copyright me I'm gonna be so nice down
from three two one yeah okay
two one
[Music]
all right if I go I think I'm gonna go
on there semi soon I wanna can I sing I
want to sing welcome back to another
episode of off the clock I am here with
somebody who which I know if you have
similar experience the interesting thing
about I think this what the hell I don't
want to see the interview I wanted to
see the guitar oh here we go
I love a choice to make
if it went the other way nobody would
have blamed to think about the small
town talk it would have saved her she
could have chosen one quick fix
[Music]
you secret got it now before it changed
her life she could have changed her mind
and changed everything
but she chose me
[Music]
she didn't quite know how to tell him
try to speak a truth like that
she didn't know where to turn to but she
knew a way to take it back right right
what she's so good she had it written
into her schedule like just another
thing to do but that box never got
checked off and I'm sitting here living
proof if it went the other way nobody
would have blamed her think of all the
small town talk it would have saved her
she could have chosen one quick fix
[Music]
she could have changed her mind and
changed everything
she chose me
[Music]
wow
wow that was so good I wanna like
made a daughter made a sister may the
dreamers the pigtails and pictures me
the wife my husband loves I'm just
thankful because
even went the other way nobody would
have blamed it think of all the small
town talk it would have saved it she
could have chosen one quick fix to get
her out of one big mess she could have
tied a different ribbon till the ending
of the story could a capture secret
gotten out before it changed your life
she could have changed her mind and
changed everything
she chose me
you guys are tripping in the chat saying
okay she does not make the blonde look
bad
I mean the blonde's got
a better boy but she does that for a
living I I was so impressed they were
both phenomenal
she chose
me is it making me want to play guitar
oh my gosh that was so pretty
that was so pretty
could have gone along quick fix
I feel went the other way and no one
would have changed okay wait
um
um I should I need to reach out to
whatever can someone message them tell
them I'm gonna be in LA
the end of April I'll go on their
podcast
uh what did I want to watch okay
um